- [Mark] All right, Tony.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Tony, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Sarasota, Florida.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid.
- Yes, I did.
My parents were based in
the entertainment field.
My father from Poland and my
mother Hungarian, father was
with the Ringling Brothers
Circus as bear trainer.
And the mother was an international model
and also produced circuses
in Las Vegas style shows.
And so I was raised in the
entertainment field 100% here
in America and overseas.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- Absolutely amazing.
When it came to family,
surroundings, friends
I had some issue being
gay and openly gay back
in the seventies, that was a
bit of a problem, but being
in the entertainment field,
it's much more accepting.
So that, that worked out.
I was just, I was a
content and happy child.
I can't say anything
negative on my childhood
traveled a lot who got the opportunity
of singing a lot of culture,
just an amazing upbringing
very worldly open to accepting everyone
religion, creed, race,
homosexuality, whatever.
We were open to everything
in our family and household.
And that made it quite a difference.
Occasional issues that did happen in life.
Something that I had suppressed
for decades was very
interesting to come to grasp
and understanding of was the
fact that at 12 years old
I did experience molestation from someone
that the family knew that
took me to a darker place
at that time being gay
thinking this was okay
because I looked preteen, I
looked like a little girl.
I acted like a little girl.
And this person took advantage of that.
Played up the whole old
little princess type thing.
And it very, it took many years
for me to, I had blocked it
out and still don't remember
a lot of the details
but remember enough that it changed me
in a certain way to where
my caring and loving
and the endearment that I wanted
to show others was stronger
because there was an innocence
that was taken at that time.
And yet even growing up
and still now I'm almost 50 years old.
I still have the heart
and the soul of a female.
So my, I care and love for everyone.
I want to make everything
better for everybody.
I'm like a mother hen, big brother
a big sister, you know,
a mother, godmother.
I try to be the real
in the circle I'm in now of sex offenders.
Something I've noticed with most
of them is they don't have support.
They don't have a family.
That's loving them or embracing them.
And sometimes family becomes
from the family we make.
I've learned that in the gay world
I guess I'll say because
drag queens do that.
They have the houses where
there's a house mother
and all these gay bies
as they will call them.
And the house mother will take them in
under their wings and help
show them what life is about
on positive and show them positivities
because of the love and nurturing.
I had growing up from all my circus family
my aunts, my circus uncles, and
and show biz family, extended family.
That still goes beyond anything.
I could imagine on several continents.
I still have that, that want
and need to help others.
The mistake I made and I
will not justify what I did
which I did touch a twelve-year-old child
in an inappropriate manner.
I will never, that will
never be justified.
I won't accept be it's
because something that
happened to me in the past
we make our own decisions
on what we're going to do.
But there's a time that my
heart will always be broken
on the fact that I hurt a
child and I affected them.
What I went through when
I was 12 was devastating
because there, it was the full
gamut of a sexual encounter.
I have no explanation as
to what transpired and why.
I, I've been trying to dig deeply
for many years on the night
that my offense took place.
It was a matter of seconds.
It was not a long-term.
It was not premeditated.
It was a short period of
time, literally seconds.
Even the mindset.
It was not there to touch a child.
I like men.
I like hairy men.
I have since I was young.
This didn't fit my criteria of what my,
my sexual interests were.
Regretful, I'm devastated.
I hurt somebody. And for someone like me
who wants to only help
others and bring positivity
that it's taken a long time
for me to forgive myself.
And I'm still working on that.
In the entertainment field.
I've been lucky. I produced shows.
I was an entertainer, singer.
I did a number of different characters
male and female, and costume designer
choreographer that world
of the entertainment field
You, it's easy to get lost
in the magic of all that.
But the purpose of
everything I've ever tried to
do was to make people forget
their troubles for a while.
And even if it's just for that hour
and a half or two hours, they
come to see the performance
Excuse me. And now I've
had to find myself again
because I hurt a child.
Because even, even
though the reality is
it was, it was seconds.
That will last a lifetime.
I know what happened to me
was a short period of time.
I, assuming, but it did.
It affected my outlook on what love is.
I'm a firm believer.
I don't, I've never
believed in one nightstands.
I prefer the idea of
love, compassion, romance
very old school that way.
But now if I could apologize
to him with all my heart, with
all of my heart, I'm sorry.
I hope with therapy, you
will be able to get better.
I hope you will get past it.
I am not a monster.
Many of us that live with
the title of sex offender.
We are not monsters.
I don't believe any of us are
but there are some people
that are truly ill.
They, they cannot help what they do.
And there were others that
Truly make mistakes
would never offend again,
there are others that
unfortunately are caught up
in this Romeo Juliet
type of situation, where
they were both underage when
they started a relationship
and then the boy or the girl became 18.
And the other was still under age.
And that becomes an issue.
And for many parents, legal
actions are then taken.
And there are many people here
in that situation that live in this park
others that are set up on
the sting operations online.
And if you were looking for
something like that online
I don't think you should.
That's the negatives.
If you need therapy, find it
but admit who you are and
what your situation is.
In my opinion, I deal with, like I say
play the endearing mother hen here.
So I hear a lot of the stories.
And I love the fact
that some are honest enough
to say they need help.
And therapy is helping them
when it's the right therapist.
And if they're going and
working on the right issue
not everybody has the same stamp on them.
As far as if you're a sex offender
you should not have the same therapy.
If you are a rapist, or
if you are a molester
or if you are someone into pornography
there are different levels.
And that's something so important
for people to understand.
We're not all the same
but under all of it, we're still human.
And we all matter.
- [Mark] What's your biggest regret?
- My biggest regret is that,
When my personal life and
professional life were spiraling
in opposite and crazy directions,
I did not stop myself.
And just take a minute to
put everything back in check.
I allowed myself very
briefly to go to a dark place
and a place that's not a norm.
That's why I still, I still
fight this within myself
trying to understand why I
would allow myself to go there.
Why I would subject someone
I barely knew to even
a microsecond of touching
them inappropriately
that I will forever have a regret.
I will try to learn, to
accept and understand.
And I'm slowly working
on that, but I still have
that's will always be a work in progress
but I think that's everyone.
But my regret is that I, I
hurt a child unintentionally
and there was no satisfaction.
That's there was no, there wasn't a reason
for me to do this.
It wasn't, it wasn't my desire.
An honest mistake.
I allowed my mind to go
to a bad, a dark place.
And,
I put myself and somebody else
in a very terrible position.
Nothing makes it okay.
When I think back
to what happened to me and certain details
he tried to make it
affectionate and kind with me.
And yet he was crossing the line.
There's no, even when we
get past that in our lives
it's still in the back of your mind.
Whether you look at it
as a positive or hurtful,
whatever, it's still there.
It's a memory that doesn't leave you.
And as a person who made that mistake
and hurt somebody, it's the same
no matter how great and
how much help I want to
give others how much I
want to do for others.
And I've always been like that.
It's nothing new.
That's just who I've been.
I want to help and nurture
others in the back of my mind.
I still, I hurt someone.
- [Mark] Do you feel
like, if what happened
to you as a child at 12 had not happened?
This may have not had,
you have not done this.
You wouldn't have done this.
- I've done, I'm still
up in the air on that.
I don't know
because I know some people
who've had absolutely
no molestation in their life
and a fairly good life and had
and offended and never had an issue.
And there was no basis
they couldn't come up with
is it possible?
Yes. I haven't seen enough studies yet
nor have I been able to come
up with the answers on my own with that?
I don't believe in placing blame
on others for one for one's actions.
I did that.
I made the mistake.
I, I'm not a huge drinker.
I've gone through a couple of periods
in my life where I would drink
alcohol sometimes to excess
But, that it was a minute
amount of times in life.
And I think
in my particular situation
that may have played a role
because you, your inhibitions,
(indistinct)
I, I do believe even if
even though it took me
very little to drink
to become intoxicated, I do believe
that alcohol did play a role in that
because I wasn't one to
drink on a regular basis.
Even now I don't drink.
I have had a couple of drinks here
and there in the past two
years, five years, really.
But I don't, I think that
had to have played a role.
It was being
in the dark place when your
world becomes spiraling
out of control, personal
life, mother passing away,
health issues around
yourself and other people.
And then you allow yourself
to take a depressant
which is alcohol.
It makes you do things that
you normally wouldn't do.
So I almost, I wanna
say it's the combination
of all those things that ball, balled
up that made that night happen.
And that very possibly what
happened as a youngster.
See, for me, it wasn't a
traumatic necessarily experience
because it was, I was treated
like the little princess.
I was, it was all beautiful.
And this is how it was supposed
to be Prince charming type
of thing.
And, then pain came and there was pain.
And that I do remember.
So I, I can't say that they go hand
in hand for myself, maybe
for others, but for myself
I don't think I can say
they go hand in hand.
I do think that the combination
of, as I say, sadness,
world spiraling out of
control and allowing myself to
have alcohol had to have played a role
in that because in any
regular frame of mind
I have say have no interest
in being with anyone
that isn't hairy and a full
Crow, a full grown man.
So in my particular case,
we find we try to make it.
I try to find the,
you can't find excuses
for what you've done.
You have to take responsibility.
But I think a combination
of all these things together
did lead to what happened
in my life and changed my
life now forever in some ways
spiritual ways and emotional
ways, maybe a positive
because I've become more
understanding about things
in the world and people in
other ways, some nightmare
- [Mark] How's your, how has
your family reacted to it?
- My father old school
European was very embracing.
Those that knew me and
do know me were surprised
and shocked, but they also
we're understanding with
they knew who I was before all this
that they knew the
caring and loving person
and the mistakes that
I've been lucky that most
of my friends and family
have overlooked the mistake.
And even though they've accepted and,
and the love is still
there, it doesn't take away.
It's still in my head.
- [Mark] How often does it come up in your
how often is it in your thoughts?
- I'm sorry.
- [Mark] How often do you revisit?
- It's actually, I, the, it's,
the, what brought me here.
The, actually being an
offender, affects me every day.
I think about it daily.
I pray on it and I try
to continue learning
not just for myself, but
listen to others and reading
doing as much research
as I can to understand
what makes this happen.
Not everyone has all the answers for me.
It's something I do.
I deal with every day.
I, it breaks my heart.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
- The most important
lesson in all of this.
When you feel your life spiraling
out of control, ask for help.
If for, you take it to another level
whether it's molestation or suicide
or driving under the influence.
If you feel yourself, spiraling
out of control in any way
shape or form, and life is
more than you can handle to me.
It's okay to ask for help where
too many people are expected
in the world to not have
problems to not need help.
And I really believe that's one
of the biggest mistakes now that you
when you asked my biggest
mistake is I didn't ask
for help before it got that far.
There's nothing wrong in admitting defeat.
And sometimes world, the
world seems to defeat us.
And the reality is when you speak
with somebody and you
put the words out there
you realize you're still more powerful
and you can conquer over everything
Ask for help.
- [Mark] How long have
you been in a wheelchair?
- Three and a half years.
I have spinal, spinal
issues and heart issues
and number of other health
issues that are altering my life.
And, but I'm still here and I stay strong.
I stay positive.
We are looking at
surgeries coming very soon
that I've had a heart
surgery two months ago
going for spinal surgery.
After another heart surgery
another heart surgery is coming
up and then spinal surgery, following that
and may not be able to
make it, help me walk
but it'll take the pain away.
And I just stay positive.
Whether I'm six foot, four standing
out or four foot seven in a chair,
I love everybody.
And I'm going to be a cheerleader
for anyone I can to help them
get through their problems
and be there for those that
need help and need to call out.
- [Mark] All right Tony.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- I enjoyed this very much.